foreign
everybody and welcome to the Sean method
I'm Sean McGinnis this is Chris Waters
hi and today we're going to try a little
bit something a little bit different you
know on this show we tend to play open
world games sandboxy games we've played
a lot of steam Early Access survival
games recently of which there are a
plethora there's a lot to choose from
but today we're mixing it up we're gonna
do a point and click adventure game or
to use the developers terminology a
point in a point-and-click thriller oh
okay all right you had me at Thriller
yes I'm prepared to be thrilled all
right well you're going to be thrilled
Chris because today we're playing Gods
will be watching I'm gonna hold you to
that promise Gods will be watching this
is a game that I first saw at PAX East
this year and it's a very narrative
driven point-and-click Adventure game
okay
um it's not an adventure game in the in
the sense of the the monkey islands and
what have you it's very pick up some
inventory items actually in them
actually I'm going to restart this
because there is a little bit of
dialogue that kind of sets the scene is
there voice acting or do we have to do
the voice acting you can do the voice
acting you chose the nomination to mess
with we got company I mean we both chose
the same voice oh yeah I'll do a
different voice the hacking system is
ready
Liam the hostages are secured
the crew we don't have any access codes
good work guys I don't know why I did a
random cartoony costume he's the
professor okay so just to set the stage
uh we're kind of like this Rebel
revolutionary organization who is trying
to hack into this computer system here
ladies and gentlemen may I have your
attention for a minute this is a
xenolifer app Zeno lifer for life what
you are being held as our guests while
we retrieve the data we need about your
outstanding research on the Medusa virus
the ducia virus seriously good job
analyzing that little [__] it's you
know what I always like it when hostage
takers complement their hostages you
know yeah you got to set them up before
you knock them down and they we will be
knocking them takes the edge off having
a gun pointed in your face the
Revolution Will greatly benefit from
your contribution to the scientific
Community now let my friends do their
work and nothing will happen to you Jack
don't let those damn guards get near us
I got them boss
always Whispers so Jack is this guy over
here he's a guy with a gun yeah uh
Shaman is this guy over here he's the
hacker Shaman keep the network stable
while I hack into their database also
I'm looking forward to the power of your
new improved hack boost tool is that a
euphemism that might be we'll find out
later this is the hack boost tool right
it won't say me coming common talks like
Mickey Mouse he does he won't see me
coming and you Abraham that's this guy
right here which guy
okay yeah orange mask guy holding more
in charge while I'm plugged into this
thing yes oh he's gonna sit in the
Professor X chair mind the hostages
gotcha don't let them get too
comfortable that they think they can
save themselves if you ignore them for
too long they'll Revolt but don't scare
them to the point of trying a suicide
Escape either while I'm plugged in I'm
counting on you to lead the team in
their tasks
a jack with his negotiations while
keeping an eye on Shaman's work and the
network status man basically keep the
situation under control until my hacking
recent reaches 100 and our missions will
be and our mission will be complete my
pleasure
and Abraham don't hesitate to ask us
anything that won't take much time
xenolifer
see no life for life okay so that sets a
stage Gods will be watching it's it's
made up of six different chapters and
they're all these very close confined
tense situations where you're like
you're managing the crew you're managing
different people it's about choosing uh
conversation choices choosing
conversation choices yeah choose the
choices uh and basically every there's
there's constantly a lot on the line and
there's a lot of weight on your
shoulders
um and that's uh a lot of people saying
this game is hard as hell 63 HH betting
five dollars you fail within five
minutes okay so there's one Werner
putting it uh more directly it gets real
really fast all right so why don't we
try something different so we've got
four hostages here
and you know what what we could do to
kind of put the fear of God in them
blast one I'm here to blast one right in
the knee oh shoot him
uh oh you can shoot him in a leg or
shoot him in the face I'll shoot him in
the face oh wow
just take him out of the equation right
away listen
yeah
purple
okay so okay damn it I'll hold them back
Abraham actually one thing I should
point out is there's more to the stage
than just this just jib the [__] out of
that guy's face there's these guards
over here and they're slowly encroaching
it's a it's kind of turn based in a way
like they don't start encroaching until
I take an action like blasting a hostage
in the face like blasting a hostage in
the face and the hostages
um their emotions and they're kind of
like General demeanor doesn't change
until I take an action as well okay
um so basically my goal is I want to
hack this whole thing because we're a
revolutionary organization that's trying
to hack into the the powerful
government's information computers yeah
yours you know life I'm a Xeno lifer OBS
now that being said uh they are counter
hacking us what so that's what yeah
that's the dude with the iPad that's
what the security bar is if it gets too
low sorry it's a Microsoft Surface Pro
it's a Microsoft Surface Pro yeah RT
model uh if the security drops too low
then what's gonna happen is uh we
basically lose access to the hacking
thing and the [__] goes wrong and it
gets Fubar and now this is the hack
boost which you'll remember right here
yeah Shaman Shaman right here he's
holding it right in his crotch where you
were gesturing with the reticle if I get
that high enough I can trigger a hack
boost which does like a big jump in
progress whereas normally the hacking
progress just kind of inches along do
you like massage Shaman's ego and bring
him cupcakes
kind of yeah let's say yes yeah let's
say yes I already kind of screwed myself
here no come on you can do it and
there's also this other room over here
where if the hostages three rooms three
rooms to deal with
this is the party room this is the party
room right here why don't you just go
there and hang out so if the hostages
get to like worked up and too antsy you
can send them there to kind of calm down
go have a shot of the Fireball and sit
down on a chair but with that being said
if they're there for too long they might
get too comfortable at which point you
have to shoot them they're just gonna
make a run for it they're going to be
emboldened by all the hot sauce and
phonograms in here yeah and they're
gonna they're gonna they're gonna make a
run for it okay like so I'm already
1920s Rum Runner so I've already shot
that guy in the head to put the fear of
God into these people okay
okay no no no back over here let's do
some hack hack packs no I still gotta
gotta take care of this uh you're gonna
what don't shoot him again come on just
shoot that guy you're just going right
oh there we go there we go and uh this
guy I'm gonna kick him just gonna give
him a good hard kick
oh she kicked him in the blood bag and
this lady I'm gonna just try to calm her
down
oh no all right so I wasn't even keeping
track of uh uh that whole situation what
just happened so that's what happens
when the security level gets too low it
was just at ninety percent but every
action you took it went down with every
action when you were abusing hostages so
I'm gonna talk to him damn it Shaman I'm
gonna reinforce the security there we go
we're back on track next I'm sorry
Abraham their Tech guy that's good I
need to keep you keep an eye on the
security status for me I'm gonna warn
you guys we're gonna fail a whole bunch
of times I might not even pass this
chapter that is a very likely scenario I
believe in you Sean all right uh so
instead of walking over there to keep
tabs on the guards I'm gonna hack this
camera
for the corridor and see how close they
are okay so there's still a little ways
off oh wait is walking over to look at
the corridor in action no it's not then
what is the point of having that
freaking screen up there it just saves
me times because you're late but just
asking him to put that up there no so
that doesn't take a turn oh right so you
said talking to them doesn't take much
time at all yeah so so the things that
are highlighted in red that takes a turn
yep the things that are highlighted in
blue you can do that anytime you want it
doesn't take a turn that's just like
extra context stuff the red is the
turn-based kind of stuff cool cool so uh
this dude has his hand on his face I
feel like he's maybe his spirit is
broken his spirit is broken he's just
gonna soil himself I'm gonna send him to
the break room so he's gonna what's
gonna happen if he freaks out too much
he's gonna do a runner you'll find out
oh my God you'll find out yeah you'll
find I'm gonna jump at you and try to
bite out your throat Rick Grime style he
might just do that uh so now security is
looking pretty good these guys aren't
too bad this lady's may be on the edge a
little bit and she can she can wait it
out yeah let's get a hack boost to go
I'm gonna hack boost
initiating hack boosts initiating hot
cool sequence are you ready Liam for it
stabilizer Network house open selective
drivers here we go
ready
hack boost ready for lunch oh wait in
the countdown ugh
right oh I did the wrong thing I did the
wrong thing I meant to uh boost I meant
to boost hack not actually deploy the
hack boost 35 success rate I'll execute
it worked it worked it worked holy [__]
yeah well technically it is percentage
based so a 35 success rate is still a
one out of three shot at getting it
generally speaking I've been waiting
until like I'm at 80 90 wow you want the
sure thing yeah no man so you got to
take some risks that's that's the Xeno
light that's Xeno that's how do you
think you get into the Xeno life yeah
so these guys are getting pretty close
so I'm gonna uh I'm gonna try to push
them back
I'm gonna have my buddy Jack shoot them
back see uh no oh she's making a run for
it not happening it's happening all
right why didn't you just make a run for
the relaxation Zone
what a fool
uh all the hostages die so if all the
hot funny maybe we should just wait
maybe we should wait until they
inevitably all die because you fail it's
entirely possible
particularly I'm gonna fail this
scenario many times before I come all
right let's keep going if I completed
Forge onward I've only completed it once
uh handling these schizo hostages isn't
easy come on let's not use that damn it
but just one piece which mental illness
have you know have it rough in life
these cards won't hesitate we are
running out of cards so expect them to
be far more aggressive okay with the
guards yeah so the guards they they
cards are you running out of human
beings oh
yeah human beings are the cards got it
so I need to go uh get the guy from the
break room because the guards only see
one live hostage and they assume I only
have one live hostage they don't know
that I have two
and you can see that he's I still a
little worked up come on man get back
out here I'm gonna nickname this guy the
professor because he looks like a
professor what's the professor's gonna
get out here and start asking questions
yeah where is Suzanne oh it's going on
uh okay she has the Cockney accent
which is laborious laborious I'm not
going to do that don't worry all right
just calm down let's calm them down have
a chat all right so he's looking better
so you read their emotions based on
their animation State like uh if he's
got his head in his hands he's really
worked up and he's gonna try to make a
run for it eventually what if he's just
clutching his stomach like he's gonna
yarf on his feet he's this is his kind
of neutral State it's when he gets
really relaxed and laid back that's when
he gets bold and that's when he's gonna
try to run after me and grab my that's
when you shoot the corpse in the leg
that's when I shoot just to show you the
real mess time
let's find out
oh so you can patch her up or him up I
can erupt yeah
so I'll uh sorry about the leg thing
my bad yeah just spray some of that
one's on me spray Some of That World Cup
it's juice on it all right listen
security yeah Security's not good we're
gonna reinforce those Busters won't get
in on my system
he's he's okay he's not too bad uh he's
he's actually that's kind of exactly the
look I want this is not really the look
I want
this one right here is uh that's not
what I'm gonna call Ideal
all right well you're all you're like
three-fifths done with the hacking
progress can we like get a hack boost
I'm gonna charge I'm gonna charge the
hackers yeah all right we're the hot
boost is a risky but over we should
Unleashed only with our alts of success
are high enough oh go go go go uh so
one thing that I need to point out right
now is that there's a standard
difficulty in this game which is hard as
[__] okay all right and it's designed
for you to die and fail over and over
and over again and learn from your
mistakes all right there is a easy
difficulty which just which doesn't
change the fundamentals of normal hard
as opposed to hard as [__] kind of it
doesn't change the fundamental gameplay
like the interactions what it does
change is like say that hack boost just
went from like five percent to 29 if I
was playing on it would go like 20 or 15
if you were playing on the harder yeah
which I'm not you are not playing on
easy just for the sake of the stream
just because we have an hour to work
with hun yeah and I want to actually
make some progress
um but just like this game as hard as it
is right now standard difficulty is much
harder gotcha yeah I think you're doing
okay though I'm doing the guards look
like they might be getting a little
close I was uh I'm actually surprised
that I'm doing okay right now because I
immediately shot a hostage in the head
listen I pulled up immediate power of
him in line uh good so let's
charge it one more time
oh they're getting pretty close all
right see so now he's muttering to
himself I need to run and oh did you
just say that yeah yeah so sometimes
you'll see their their thoughts above
their head maybe you should kick him in
his face
because kick
upset him
uh oh come I'll try to calm him down a
little bit all right now this guards are
good Iris could mean the end of the
human race
you understand what your what forces
you're working with here
oh [__] what are we doing this is even
right see now Jack the guy on my team is
starting to question me what the hell
just because you murder a few hostages
he starts losing his nerve that's not
the Xeno life uh Jack come on do it
shoot him
Jack
deal with you I'm going to reprimand you
this is not the Survivor I remember from
The Legend desert this is not the time
to second guess me swallow your feelings
and start shooting there we go
uh okay sergeants no he has a sultry
whisper
exciting phone
yeah oh what
professor professor are you [__] up
Professor [__] up on the plus side I
only have one Hostage to deal with
Carolyn was just yelling call him he's
cracking under the pressure on the plus
side I've only got the one Hostage to
deal with right now he's a little uh
he's a little worked up so why don't we
calm him down there we go how did he say
man come on oh yeah that's my bed
all right we're going to reinforce
security
yeah uh Vinnie Caravella just signed on
he's playing retro booster cool cool so
it's important to keep track look at how
close your hacking progress is to to
success
gonna
charge it one more time one more time
remember
the heck boost is a risky maneuver do
you think we should roll the dice on I
think you should maybe calm the hostage
calm the hostage yeah because it looks
like your normal hacking progress is
going to get you there in like an action
or two
well there's two bars oh what that
second bar too and that's the second bar
oh God damn it yeah come on I thought
you were doing super well what do you
think this is baby Town frolics
apparently not all right calm this guy
listen dude
I could use some time in the break room
no you can't this time in the break room
because then the guards will think I
have zero hostages that's what a escapee
would say so this means I've got like
two turns before they deploy their uh
gas grenade uh this is not looking good
Chris
it really went South when the professor
made a run for it what why didn't you
just like kneecap I'm doing it I'm Gonna
Roll the Dice on the hack boost all
right
go for it
blah blah blah blah
chat ready
that boost ready for launch begin the
countdown three three also three go
yes it worked all right that was awesome
but they're so close they're so close
they're right up in that face that
dude's face all right jack I need you to
just do it oh
okay now you have no hospital I have
zero hostages and this is kind of the
point and remember that time you guys
were asking in the twitch chat what
happens when all the hostages die
it's not good uh my only hope is that
they're so far back that they can't see
that I have zero hostages like maybe
they think this guy's still alive
because he's propped up against the wall
no here's what you do okay
you already shot this guy in the chest
you shoot him there a few more times
yank his head off and go put it on the
other dude's head it's a little Macabre
it's a little bit granted but that's the
Zeno life man that's true you know all
right I'm gonna charge it
all right The Jig Is up here we go
uh-oh shooting their little grenade
thing oh you got you got banged
wait what that's it game over bro why
don't they just do that immediately
because there's hostages and it would
have killed them oh
it was an explosion yeah it wasn't like
a non-lethal that was definitely a local
grenade you're having progress was it 71
that was not bad I did kill all the
hostages so that one's on me Shaman lost
four percent of data due to security
does that mean that it sets back the
hacking progress or okay when the
security thing gets triggered then you
actually lose a little bit of progress
your approach to the situation has been
aggressive
unfairness that is accurate because I
did immediately kill a hostage yeah all
right let's go again all right should I
not kill what if I killed three hostages
immediately this is one year ago
okay can you skip all this stuff
all right here's what we're gonna do you
just go down the line and then you don't
have as many hostages to to pay oh my
goodness
which one are you going to keep around
boom
Don't force me to do this
just go ahead and really I need to run
uh oh
here we go oh here we go I'm pulling a
power move on this lady now all right is
calm her down now I just got to turn
Super calm Abraham what are you doing
yeah I thought it would be a good idea
to shoot three of them in the head just
keep hacking Liam I got this handling
these schizo hostages isn't easy okay
damn it with just one hostage left these
guards won't hesitate
crap hey hey hey hey no it's fine it's
fine it's fine I'm very convincing at
calming people down no she's not buying
it she is not buying it uh just it's
okay calm down relax all right yeah you
should there you go there you go regret
your life decisions that brought you to
this point that's all that's a very
soothing way for suspend your hostage
these guards are still a little bit of a
ways off so why don't we go ahead and uh
going to reinforce security
more likely than not it's gonna work is
this lady uh she fixing to run
oh yeah she's not good squirrely
maybe you should give her some time
in the break room and I'm pretty sure
you know what I need to find out what
can you trade
ask for net stability ask them ask the
guards to move back or ask for medicine
now you'll notice that if I do trade her
you'll have no love I'll have no
hostages and then they'll just shoot me
a grenade I'm pretty sure that if I do
send her to the room they're gonna see
that I don't have hostages in the
immediate vicinity and they're going to
shoot a grenade
oh she you think she's gonna do it
executing the hack boost
three two one that's the key yeah
all right doing okay
see made killing all the other where
your definition of okay is what do you
mean lying on what do you mean see the
most challenging thing about this game
is all the plates spinning right and you
have fewer plates to spin if you murder
three of the hostages immediately right
yeah
okay so she's getting a little worked up
so we're gonna calm her down a little
bit
you really should have studied
oh yeah these guys are super close Jack
can you do something do an attack Jack
what what are we oh no Jack we even do
it
uh Jax okay sweet sweet jack maybe you
should apologize should I try
apologizing this time I'm sorry man just
shoot these dudes I'm sorry
when I shot three people in the head
immediately without even thinking uh
I lost sight of our ideals let's keep
the violence at its kind of a look
don't tell that to the professor well
that's all these gaping neck holes lined
up against the wall over here let's keep
the violence at its minimum yes sir
that's the man I respect now see
freaking shoot those dudes it's like the
old saying goes where are they they're
not even on the camera it's easier to
ask for forgiveness than for permission
the dudes are not even on the camera
they're like right here we're [__]
they're up returning the grill yeah
they're right here they're standing
right there so you shoot them no
he can't even attack them at this point
yeah just talk to these guys
cool no you're talking to him you can
you can't blast them with your little
blasto gun click on the guards
I can talk to the guys
shut up and drop your weapons no they
don't really wow that's not you know
that's not helpful guys
uh negotiate you maybe just negotiating
don't you take another step where people
will start dying here okay take it easy
we're holding our position yeah see
there we go they're holding their
position directly on the other side they
could literally hold out a gun and be
this close to your head all right uh
that lady's gonna do a runner she's
gonna do a runner I'm gonna accomplish
that
no she did not nope that didn't work uh
everything's really bad here reinforced
security there we go yeah
and uh hostage honest insult McAfee
virus gone they're gonna they're gonna
stay out of my system yeah we're good
pretty good McAfee jokes let's get some
every time what do you think should we
charge the hack boost
about to soil herself she's okay though
because she could be worse she's kind of
like a she could be super jittery she's
like a four out of five right now on the
jittery wanna run off and uh suicide run
scale yeah that's a good scale all right
let's let's I'm going to
charge
the cards are just standing there yeah
Jack did a pretty good negotiation with
those guys I wonder how long that's
gonna last so are they just gonna stand
there and not even attack you as long as
you have a hostage
oh it feels like they should have
another move here like they should just
blast Shaman in his skull face yeah I
think that they will
eventually stop holding position and
just come after us
these guys are gonna get a little
Ireland says you need to negotiate with
the guards again like every three turns
or so every three turns yeah
calm her down oh [__] uh oh
no but there's a hostage [__]
collateral demo damn Joe's
push the situation it's because you got
all your murder out in one at the
beginning and then you did a lot of not
murder balanced because the fulcrum was
right here ah okay let's try this again
here we go all right Chris
so first things first murder pack the
camera no no we tried that already okay
yeah we double try that one yeah we
tried that one we most certainly did try
that one uh first things first is we are
going to charge the hack boost because
they look like they're okay right now
they seem okay
charging up scientists now do I want to
charge it up another time or
do I want to just go for it should I
roll the dice here what do you think at
53 yeah yeah flip the coin man we're
gonna flip the coin make a move here all
right execute hack boost fortune favors
the Bold there we go Liam how's your
tiles
stabilizing Network paths hoping the
selected drivers
that's more of a Mr Hanky
back who's ready for launch begin the
countdown there we go we got pull hanky
on the team now what happened Executives
fails oh [__] it didn't work it didn't
work it didn't work oh you just Zapped
him in his
yeah that's my that's okay all right
there with iPads pretty crafty all right
so here's been running now some of that
uh Windows 8.1 I'm gonna send him to the
break room
he's a little antsy
let's
charge that hack boost see these guys
are they're getting a little too calm
you know oh yeah look at that dude just
last straight lounging uh did they get
jittery if you start you need to
negotiate with the guards or something
here I don't know man they're really
close I wanna I wanna fire back on them
to be honest with you
see yeah there we go see the thing about
hostages are a little bit less relaxed
because you started blasting for yeah
yeah see there look this guy got nervous
she's really nervous
I need to calm her down are you sure you
shouldn't shout at her
no because reverse psychology you think
so no I don't know okay she's slightly
better not afraid of dying she's just
afraid of xenolifers running the world
let's see he doesn't know about that
life let's see how our buddy in the
break room is doing
I'm gonna just check on him real quick I
feel like maybe he's
if he's getting too oh look look at this
dude can you go step on his junk you get
the
[__] back here buddy I will not have you
Max in or relaxing in the break room
none of those will be acceptable oh look
at this guy
he's all right oh look at these two
dudes sitting with their this out
they're bits you need to kick that dude
in the face I so I'm I'm kind of worried
more about her than these guys freaking
out all right what do you think should I
calm her down should I go for the hack
boost
the guards are they're getting close she
is real amped yeah she's pretty amped
there we go oh this guy's see now this
guy oh look at him he's starting to run
yeah I mean
blossom in the knee or just kick I could
do two birds with one stone if I was to
shoot the guards back I think that's a
good tip also echoed By Carolyn Pettit
in the twitch chat
all right there we go he went to just
moderately moderately relaxed I think
you should hack boost actually what I'm
going to do is I'm going to send her to
the break room yeah you need to take a
break lady all right now I'm gonna I'm
gonna hack with your crazy should I
charge all the boiled legs
should I go 62 man I don't know I'm
gonna try one more all right oh [__]
what why is charging a risk oh because
the security was bored security was low
what
all right well your heck you're
guaranteed a hack boost but this guy's
about to do I think you should kick this
dude in his face this guy yeah look at
him he's getting chippy
[__] down sit back down back down now
this guy wants to run
you know what I can afford to lose one
yeah are you gonna let him free are you
gonna blast his ass well that's the
thing is if if I let him free it eases
those two but at this point those guys
are really easy yeah so I can let them
know what happened it would behoove me
to teach them a lesson yeah I need to
get them on edge a little bit yeah
because this guy look at him he's
propped up he's rearing to go Johnny and
Jeremy jumpsuit over there are really
just feel like they they're about to
make a move and be a hero all right hack
boost ready for lunch begin the
countdown
this doesn't work at 92 I'm gonna be
smoking mad I'm pretty sure this is
gonna happen oh yeah I'm a super hacker
extraordina Mario okay
all right hacking progress we're getting
there slowly but surely
uh how's this lady doing you got your
your I think she's doing better she
seems to be calmed I'm gonna bring her
back maybe I'll send the professor in
Professor is a little yeah maybe you
should shoot at the guards
although the professor is quite jittery
just in there well these two dudes both
Johnny and Jeremy jumpsuit are about
ready to go
maybe I could trade one of them
I could trade him for them to get back
sure give it a shot you think I should
do that this soon I don't know
just you give him a kick kick him no if
I kick him then that's gonna spur him to
run because he's just a kick it's just a
kick I don't know kick the other guy
then this time what I'm gonna trade him
I'm gonna try trading this guy I'm gonna
trade him for smokes I'm gonna ask the
guards to go back let's see how far back
the guards go
yeah all right get out of here buddy hey
and that helped him out too professor's
feeling a lot better yeah you might live
to see the end of this day professor
if you don't do anything stupid
oh no what is he strangling you just
kick him you're a soldier he's a
freaking scientist oh wow all right so
that's what happens when they get a
little too comfortable Jack shot his
mid-riff out all right so now I've only
got two suddenly trading that one guy
seems like a bad idea no man you got
plenty you got you gotta just yeah
double down on hack boosts
let's go to town on these hack boosts
yeah
oh no [__] I didn't mean to execute it
wow rolling the dice I do that because
they're right next to each other
are you really really saying that this
is a hard game and you just didn't aim
correctly
I'm saying is that I didn't spend enough
time looking at the menu I just saw hack
boost and clicked it oh my goodness
terrible hostage taker hey hey I'm gonna
call it it's gonna work it's gonna work
I'm telling you all right yeah I like
your confidence
[__] that did not work I don't like your
execution
all right so I'm gonna calm this guy
down calm down we all know you're just
an Adjunct professor anyways you don't
even have tenure
charge my hack boost a little bit uh
Maybe
send them to the break room no he's not
he's not that amped up your Security's
getting kind of low it is
oh distracted you know what we're gonna
use this as an opportunity
oh what he's all right he's saying you
have one hostage so we got to be careful
yeah yeah that's it you're gonna die put
the fear of God in you yeah God's or be
watching Gorge will be watching
all right 66 percent
bank that's a good that's a good shot I
would take those odds okay
stop for the old booster
oh fingers crossed pray for Mojo
ah [__]
wow you are frying that dude's brain
blast the guards again
is Jack cool with all this blasting of
the guards I feel like Jack as long as I
don't
go too crazy on the hostages then Jack
is fine
meanwhile speaking of hostages let's
check in the break room
working on his dissertation or what
oh yeah oh look at you look at you
pondering the mysteries of the universe
he is to become get back into this get
get back into the [__] yeah it's gonna
get real shitty I'm gonna warn you right
now yeah
I want to use gonna I don't know get
kicked
maybe not yet
they're both uh
sitting in like what looks like a real
uncomfortable
I'm going to give her a good kick
do you think or should I
kick never hurt anyone
I mean metaphorically speaking literally
it does kicking hurts kicking does hurt
and I feel like kicking her would also
spook the professor can you make them
sit really close to each other so you
kick her and then her like head Bonks
into his and it's like a double kick
all right I'm going for the hack boost
again
81 percent that's pretty good but your
security is kind of low yeah let's do it
yeah yeah all right the guards are close
the security is low we got a situation
get the get the hell back back
okay no one needs to get hurt except for
that one guy who got really hurt oh yeah
this guy well that was his fault too
yeah you know he's the one listen that
was self-defense no jury in the universe
is going to convict you on that no that
dude ran at me and he tried to rip the
gun out of my hand I thought he was
trying to choke you take a water break
yeah I don't know you need a your
security situation yeah I mean obviously
step number one is to reinforce security
there we go all right I'm doing
everyone's feeling good your hack
progress is going well your guards are
back I'm feeling really strong about
this Sean yeah let's just not blow it
let's stay frosty so step one we are
going let's not click on the wrong thing
charge hack boots yeah it says charge
literally the first word in the sentence
so look at the charge part not the hack
boost part yeah just charge okay that's
a mistake that's the real big difference
okay uh these guys are nice and neutral
you could Shout at the professor he's I
don't know give him a shout I know
because if like if his legs are on the
ground that's when he's really laid back
they're fine they're fun
maybe they're starting to smell the
insides of that other guy are starting
to like off gas that's entirely possible
yeah guards are getting a little while
getting a little close damn look at him
just what is this you know that's all
over Liam's boots oh yeah Liam's getting
[__] up if Liam changes posture he's
gonna be arresting his foot on that
guy's shattered kidney oh yeah yeah
absolutely and Liam is plugged into the
Matrix right now he has no idea that
there's viscera all over his yeah he's
gonna wake up and be like God damn it
these are my hacking boots these were my
hacking boots come on please give me
plus three to hacking skill
plus one to Charisma but now that's all
shot
all right these I'm gonna try to push
him back
all right there we go yeah I feel like
you're going to die reinforce security
all right I'm gonna charge one more time
I don't even know if you need that man I
mean I think I just I'm so close all
right see that yeah actually you might
probably don't even need the hack those
yeah you can probably just let the hack
boost thing lie and just manage hostages
and cards
chat with them
say hey what's up we're gonna calm him
down
our database is highly protected this
won't be as easy as you planned
thanks professor
Professor idiot
yeah you know what Professor [__] you
and one to grow on
yeah got the data there we go what
happens now eat it Professor you can do
one as far as I'm concerned
what now what yes how do you guys Evac
let's get out of here
you'll never leave this place alive
all right dude's gonna iPad you no
what wait it's different this time oh no
Abraham Jack oh what shot what's just
making an escape is he climbing an
elevator or is he like I think she
trapped I think he got on an elevator
he's the owner maybe he's in a jail
evader is he in like a meat Belt being
transported to like a a meat he's
Spiderman is he like Mission
impossibling out of there or is he gonna
be gutted and packaged for the holistic
Empire to digest and snack form you know
what I kind of regret not shooting the
professor because I really had a free
move at the end there you did because I
was so close yeah and I could have just
popped him one he could have just
blasted I could have blasted him for
being all professorial drop your weapon
Liam get away leave the revolution
don't worry about us
we could do this
I won't let you die here I promise
whatever just go go just go yeah
easy difficulty
that probably would have taken me about
30 extra tries on normal difficulty
because it's so much more incremental
when you do your attack charges that is
flattering to you to estimate that I'd
say seven tries
all right what do we got here gods have
been watching
free to hostage
oh is this like stats on what other
players did yeah so this is kind of like
what Telltale does with their uh
adventure games you can see what other
players have done my attitude was soft
that time it was quite a departure from
uh when I shot three of them immediately
no questions asked it looks like soft
has been the the most successful
approach there
you so you don't kill the hostage yeah I
did it was the guy who uh fought back at
me your favorite demand guards Retreat
why would you demand a medicine is that
because you just shoot people's legs if
you shoot people's legs too much and you
run out of medicine then you need to ask
for more medicine
because I think there's like a little
medicine cabinet next to Shaman when
he's hacking and you get like three leg
repair sprays sure
nice work Sean nice work so this one
we're definitely not going to pass this
20 days of empty words because we
probably got like well we've got about
20 minutes of the show left some other
ship The Matriarch xenolifers Mothership
that's me
three days before the hacking this is
Sergeant burden communicating from Xeno
life
requesting encrypted report type 6 to
the everdesk company
new knowledge
initiating secure channel the asterisk
six
Sergeant it's been three months since
your last transmission
this is Yoda I think this is Yoda on
meth this is Mission protocol dictates
at least a reporter for two weeks
wasn't my choice sir there's been a lot
of activity
viruses falling into the hands of the
Xena life or what happened
it hasn't yet come down calm down Liam
is planning to assault one of the
holistic Empires space Labs the plan is
to steal their research about the Medusa
virus
we cannot allow that to happen
the Medusa rifles
all right we gotta change it up no I'll
do the guy okay
these are your new orders limit
Ed Frank gown
agent you're a mole see
this is a little bit of uh asynchronous
storytelling
in your orders eliminate Liam and
sabotage his plans sir sir
enium's Trust
with a few extra months hey you what do
you know we could achieves in our life
as peaceful dismantling or something
have you lost your mind sergeant we
can't allow a terrorist organization to
have a weapon of mass destruction
you know life was not terrorists they
have ideas of Revolution but they are my
genocidal I know the guy sir
keep talking like that and we'll
consider your loyalty compromise
sergeant
xenonifer is the enemy and we must it
must be neutralized by any means
necessary hey we need more time over
here what are you doing sergeant
listen to me listen to me bro I'll take
responsibility for whatever action zero
life for carries out with that uh Medusa
virus why is why is Sylvester Stallone
in this game he got a little Stallone
yeah here we go
hey if the time comes by and won't
hesitate okay and put a bullet in Liam's
in
for killing for ugly fool is uh only
gonna unleash a walk it's gonna cause a
lot of resources and lives to the ever
doozy
trust me trust me I got this under
control
that was good oh who are these what is
going on here oh this is this torture
time this is torture time all right so
you're
this is the leather daddy over here
that's beef that's the leather day beef
the leather daddy and this is a cool
Irving the guy with sunglasses cool cool
Irving not to be confusion beast and
leather daddy
all right cool Irving what do you want
what do you want from me here yeah we're
doing voice
shower time sorry did I wake you up
what's up you look confused let's
introduce ourselves my name is Irving uh
they say it right
my name is cool Irving and the big boy
with a funny helmet is beef the leather
day
he doesn't speak much but he is a good
fella unless you piss him off that ain't
gonna happen am I right
cut the crap out the crib what do you
want so burden is this guy he's uh he's
the guy we've been playing what do you
want yes all right
relax you don't want to push things here
trust me my boss wants to know about you
the usual drill age sex location
oh and also he wants to know what the
[__] you were doing in our lab wow
anyway first questions who is your boss
oh you get you can click on yeah so
there's different options I can provoke
him I can bag him I can think about it
I can lie which apparently there's a 10
chance of it working or I could just
straight up confess
just spill the beans I'm gonna provoke
them I need to see the thing is
on that last chapter yeah I think we
proved that pulling immediate power
moves is the best way to succeed it's
the best way to then later succeed when
you don't do that when you do a
different move
what's wrong are you done talking oh
okay
tell me everything about your leader
can you have Jack do something
I can have him provoke
don't be shy now show me what those Big
Ape hands can do
oh
who is your leader and what is he
planning
uh
uh one more provoke
oh
your Leader's name was something like
crappy Rebel right correct me if I'm
wrong damn it cool Irving sick burn
Jack's gonna think about it hmm
oh no oh double punch double punch it's
getting real Punchy up in here uh now
I'm starting to slump over a little bit
which is not good that is uh that's a
bad that's bad news
so what's your Leader's name it's just a
name it won't hurt anybody
but you
uh beg him maybe
don't stop you'll have to interrogate it
for us perhaps you aren't familiar with
the concept of torture oh no oh cool
Irving is really laying out the punch
attacks wool Irving is kind of a dick
bag isn't he
um
well let me think about it I'm not sure
should I try to lie yeah
our leader is Brian Kern Smith also
known as the Empire Destroyer it makes
sense doesn't it I don't know next
question
Alexander stop cool it beef look at what
time it is
we'll miss the holistic baseball league
gentlemen you'll have to excuse us I
hope you enjoy your first session of
torture nice work yeah good lying it's
been nice Irving thank you for your time
look at Beef the leather daddy he
doesn't want to give up on this he likes
no he's he's better he hasn't even
broken a sweat yet oh yeah
nice hearing thing straight time
good night fellas
all right you made it past the first
punch attacks yeah flurry of punch times
Punch Time flurry you guys gonna like
pow-wow here real quick
so you think we've been through worse
than this
we're alive aren't we for now let's just
focus on staying that way
until when I don't know but as long as
we're still breathing we might have a
chance
don't do say anything stupid we have to
choose our words wisely
it's not that I care about giving up
information about Xeno lifa but as soon
as this lunatic knows everything he
wants we are dead
sounds
solid plan
shut up and get some rest the worst is
yet to come
I like that one I like that one a lot
they've got very different voices oh no
oh beef is back cool Irving is back
here it is
black and white thing but the orange
light of my cigarette oh and I wasn't
blonde kind of lame with a heavy metal
t-shirt and long hair
I lived in a world made of concrete and
every day you got to see people with
black bags in their heads
best part of that is beef the leather
daddy didn't exist no offense no offense
and I tortured those poor Bell black bag
heads
damn it was fun
one day strange hobo with a green-eyed
gas masking by said
your world was made in less than 72
hours I mean what kind of job [__] is
that man
hey snap it out and start hitting us
please
man how rude
why is he a beatnik now he's cool Irving
man what kind of dude do you think cool
Irving is
uh
what were you looking for at our lab
all right so apparently your chances of
lying successfully Works its way up with
every action yeah
so I'm gonna think
hey are you deaf
oh no oh wow no no oh what did he do to
your knees chopped my knee with that
little Tomahawk of his oh jeez what did
you steal from our database
uh
uh bad it's too early to beg man all
right I think I still got a little
provoking left or live your line just
went up to 42 percent
oh
that looked painful oh that's a hammer
not a tomahawk okay that explains why my
leg hasn't fallen off now why are you
interested in our research
country
we're trying to delete an embarrassing
mail we sent you while we were drunk
that seems like a pretty obvious lie
burden
cool Irving thinks that oh no
no no
not Jackie Jack has nothing to do with
this
you should respect your privacy
from us all right let's have Jack come
on Jack wow burden is not we just have
Jack go straight to it just confess
leave burden like high and dry yeah
actually I'm gonna have Jack bag
I don't think I can resist much longer
no no no more no more
oh you are gonna lose a leg oh
you have a bad all right you know what
Jack is maybe he should think about it
for a second no thinking they always
they always they always Pummel you after
the thinking
I'm gonna they always Pummel you after
well you after the thinking no I
shouldn't confess because Jack is pretty
a week of constitution yeah maybe Jack
should confess is that going to be
different although burden is the one
who's taken a much I'm gonna have to
provoke him because he's in slightly
better shape also he has way sicker pecs
than you
did you ask yourself alone or did Irving
pick your leather daddy pants for you
oh yeah
oh did he get chanked in the belly yeah
a little Hammer punch to the gut
I don't know what that is
uh should I confess I feel like like you
should try to lie should I try to lie
should I go for the lie okay okay
he's gonna buy it nope nope nope cool
Irving uh uh this is not buying it
all right
ah one more beat downs oh oh ouch oh
you put those beers in the fridge I
could really use one you dig
enjoy them
thanks man I'll bring you one if you
survive for a month
let's go cool cats beef love beer beef
one beer
foreign
I'm out of voices to do I'm sorry but I
need you alive I'll kill you when we
escape if you want but I don't have a
chance if I have to resist this madman's
wrath alone
okay well this is the last favor I do
for you
sugar
whoa oh what whoa
who invited cyborg Ninja
what's up Ryden
or Liam
sorry I'm so late you didn't think Xeno
rifle would lay you down
thanks to the gods get us out of here
I'm sorry but that's not a good idea oh
God damn it what no [__]
where he are in a prison located in one
of the wandering moons of the holistic
you think it's too late for God's will
be watching to get a copy editor I
really wish uh the the people who didn't
develop this game uh English is not
their first language by and large like
the quality of the writing is good yeah
but you do encounter these random typos
and uh it takes you out of the moment a
little bit all right Liam what the hell
we are in a prison located in one of the
one the wandering moons of the holistic
Empire this giant rock is too heavy too
heavy guarded it's been a miracle I got
this far I don't think we can make it
together hell even I don't know if I can
make it back alive then why the hell are
you here
sit on
sit up what is the plan I know you have
one Liam
a burn became Russian yeah he did he
really did he went straight Slavic on
you're right I may be a suicidal herd
but I'm a suicidal idiot seeing a lifers
preparing rescue operation
it isn't gonna be easy but nothing
withstands a clever plan all right
I need you to endure 20 days of torture
what 20 20 days of torture damn it Liam
I'll give you a hint we're not going to
survive 20 days of torture on this
stream if you've got about four minutes
left 20 days all right come on let's go
I need you what what you know clever
plans usually aren't the quickest but
that's why I'm here to help you in that
matter I already located a nursery above
this floor I can sneak in and steal
medication for you medicine can restore
your health so you can endure longer
painkillers will allow you to resist
more pain so that bastard's torture
methods won't be as effective wow but
you won't recover as fast as usual from
your injuries I feel like we're pretty
down and out right now yeah we should go
for the and I don't know medication
anything else or if you prefer I can
gather information to help you deal with
your torturer it's easier to lie if you
know what your captor is interested in
well baseball we know that yeah beer
baseball and beer and have in weird
dreams and also I think he's probably
Irving probably has a secret crush on
beef the leather daddy sure but he's not
willing he's way repressing it oh yeah
he's a big time repressed he does not
even understand his true feelings no he
does not he's terrified of them probably
that's why he's such a dick bag yep you
are a smart man Abraham you can survive
this more
hooray
uh healing kit please
these guys are about to die
aren't they gonna notice when you all to
start feeling better and I'm feeling
like real jaunty all right hey I'm gonna
provoke you some more
ah [__] that healing kit did not do a
great dude I told you this guy was a
beatnik
dude yeah
yeah man I miss me some karaoke action
do you like karaoke
more threats worked in the song
all right we got two minutes left I'm
just gonna provoke this dude until he
kills me and that's gonna be the Stream
Dooby Doo [__] yourself Dooby Doo crazy
sort of [__]
guy I gotta tell you
to run what did you steal from our
database
a little [__] like you won't get much
from us
although no no no oh he's digging around
in your face Parts not the teeth oh what
did you just pocket I always have so
many teeth to steal why are you
interested in our research baby ah
I'm gonna have
Jack provokes beef the other day how
many hours do you spend in the gym
oh what you just give him a little rub
down yeah he just did a little cheek
dosey doe that's a that's a move
broken again yeah my grandchildren are
going to love this story no no uh-oh no
it's going to take another one of those
things out it's fine I got like how many
like how many teeth do people have like
90 30 out of 30 28 18 36 25 25. why do
you have an odd number of teeth Chris
look I had some wisdom teeth out but not
all of them
tell me about what you found in our lab
uh
lie
reinstall the worm to spy on all your
conversations you know all those toys
you buy for Alexander yeah we know too
that was funny
he's the penguin now he's the penguin
now yeah
oh my teeth
tree
burden answer me burden
buddy I think burden died from lack of
teeth
well [__] happens
oh delightful man you have to endure 20
days 20 days seems like a lot I feel
like it would it would jump like
you like one of those is a day but you
probably don't have to do one two three
four five all in a row right because
that's a lot that would take a long ass
time maybe yeah I'm not sure your
attitude has been suicide
my attitude has been suicide
that is accurate
oh that is delightful that's our motto
for this Tuesday all right guys well
that does it for today's episode of the
Sean method thank you very much that was
fun Gods will be watching is the name of
the game Gods will be watching it comes
out on Steam and very soon I won't say
in a couple weeks uh when are we gonna
put up that Kickstarter we're gonna do
for alternate voice packs for all the
characters we should do that I think we
should all we need is probably like a
good 500 bucks yeah for recording fees
gotta record it we gotta record we're
gonna buy some throat lozenges we're
gonna have to spend some time renting
VHS tapes to learn weird accents that's
true the Russian accent is a little off
yeah uh we have to improve our accent
count so that we're not just repeating
Rocky and beatnik and Russian accent guy
all the time
um anyways uh we have the lobby coming
up today yeah 2 p.m Pacific Time come on
back we're gonna have video games to
play it'll be fun yeah it'll be good and
uh make sure to come back to the Sean
method next week next Tuesday at 11AM
specific oh I'll be out next Tuesday so
I'm going to need you to host for me yo
I your attitude has been suicide
thanks for watching Everybody we'll see
you later
thank you